[Musica]
Noi abbiamo un obiettivo
insieme abbiamo lottato Siamo caduti
e ci siamo sempre rialzati
[Musica]
non è facile ma non smettiamo mai di
sognare nuovi traguardi
e sfidare i nostri limiti ci piace
accarezzare la vita e la nostra corsa
non finisce mai
solo così ci sentiamo liberi
solo così siamo felici
e seguiamo sempre nuovi obiettivi
per andare oltre
obiettivo 32024
[Applauso]
Buongiorno a tutti quello che avete
appena visto è un piccolo Premio di
obiettivo 3 obiettivo 3 è un progetto
ideato da Alex Zanardi subito dopo le
olimpiadi di Rio nel 2016 che mirare a
reclutare avviare sostenere
concretamente ed economicamente quante
più persone
disabili al ad intraprendere un'attività
sportiva il titolo stesso rappresenta lo
scopo del progetto e cioè all'interno
del più vasto
numero di disabili avviati allo sport
individuare almeno tre che siano capaci
di impegnarsi
concretamente in un'attività in una
disciplina sportiva fino a conseguire le
qualificazioni alle alle Paralimpiadi il
progetto nasce Quindi come tre d'union
fra il mondo della disabilità è quello
sportivo
traducendosi Nei fatti in un'azione
concreta cercare di
[Musica]
importanza sociale
a maggio a cinque anni dalla sua
fondazione avvenuta nel maggio del 2017
obiettivo 3 ha già reclutato più di 120
atleti e io ne faccio parte dall'inizio
essendo stato uno dei primi 5 atleti
selezionati
Ma perché vi parlo di obiettivo 3 più In
generale del dello Sport come vedete
sono sono in carrozzina e lo sono dal
dall'aprile del 2012 Dopo un incidente
avevo 31 anni e
all'epoca tutto mi sembrava possibile
tutto nelle nelle mie mani
facevo un lavoro che mi piace tantissimo
avevo una compagna uscivo con gli amici
facevo speleologia che per chi non lo
sapesse significa che andava in grotta
Insomma facevo quello che né più né meno
facevano tanti miei coetanei e
l'improvviso la vita chiaramente mi è
cambiata in un battito di ciglio Diciamo
che mi sono trovato
costretto a guardare le cose sotto e non
è un eufemismo sotto una diversa
prospettiva
a volte per scherzarci sopra e spiegare
bene a cercare di spiegare bene la
situazione propongo l'esempio del
dell'oroscopo non so se avete presente
quando sui quotidiani in fondo ad ogni
segno zodiacale troviamo i vari aspetti
amore Salute E Lavoro Beh diciamo che in
quel periodo dalle quattro stelle che
avevo più o meno tutti gli aspetti mi
sono ritrovato ad averne una se non
addirittura Zero
quindi di colpo i miei capisaldi le mie
certezze sono sono
evidentemente cambiate se non
addirittura sparite
Molte sono rimaste fortunatamente gli
amici la famiglia però
accettare la situazione non è non è per
tutti neanche per per chi dista di
fianco quindi i primi mesi li ho dovuti
dedicare chiaramente a me stesso nel
cercare di rendermi più autonomo il
prima possibile il tornare a guidare è
stato un primo vero passo Perché
l'essere liberi e autonomo e autonomi
nel decidere dove quando
andare come dice una famosa pubblicità
non non ha prezzo anche l'esser tornati
al mio precedente lavoro aiutato tanto
quello che mi mancava in quel in quel
momento era tornare a fare un'attività
fisica
Oddio non che non ne facesse abbastanza
in fase di riabilitazione però mi
mancava quell'attività fisica intanto da
poterla fare insieme ai miei amici come
quando
volevo ma poi quell'attività fisica che
mi desse Quella scarica di adrenalina
che non che non mi facesse pensare i
problemi quotidiani insomma E qui
entrati in gioco obiettivo tre grazie
ad un amico sono venuto a scoprire del
dell'esistenza del progetto ho inviato
la mia candidatura E dopo qualche
settimana mi sono ritrovato a parlarne
con con Alex Zanardi
e Questo in sintesi è l'esordio del
diciamo del mio percorso da atleta di
paraciclismo Per chi non lo sapesse il
paraciclismo è evidentemente la
disciplina del ciclismo adattata a
persone disabili
giusto qualche info i primi prototipi di
bici
attrezzate risalgono ai primi anni del
XX secolo mentre le prime bici sono dei
degli anni sessanta del
secolo scorso il paraciclismo segue le
stesse regole del dell'usiai che
dell'Unione ciclistica internazionale
che prevede appunto diverse competizioni
adattate alle varie disabilità o su
pista o su strada
le prime competizioni vere e proprie
sono nate negli anni 80 mentre nel 98
nel 1998 gli è stata la prima edizione
dei campionati del mondo e dal 2009
è nata una competizione che si chiama il
Giro d'Italia in And Bike che è diciamo
cerca di ripetere quel giro d'Italia
classico
per darvi un'idea le gare a seconda
appunto del tipo di competizione variano
da allora alle alle due ore due ore e
mezza
Insomma fate con le braccia potete
immaginare che non che non sono gare
agevoli quindi ho scoperto impegnandomi
nel In questo sport ho scoperto la
fatica e l'importanza degli allenamenti
perché per fare agonismo ad un certo
livello senza per questo diventare dei
Campioni insomma gli allenamenti variano
dai 4 ai 5 allenamenti a settimana tra
palestra e allenamenti condotti in
strada che quando vengono condotti in
questo periodo potete immaginare non
sono neanche dei più agevoli e dei più
comodi
e
quindi sì
ho subito constatato però potuto
partecipando alle mie prime gare ho
conosciuto nuovi amici ho conosciuto
nuove realtà ho ricevuto nuovi stimoli e
soprattutto ho potuto constatare un
netto miglioramento di quelle che erano
le mie condizioni fisiche ma soprattutto
psichiche perché è questo che fa lo
sport ci fa star bene e
soprattutto ci fa staccare dai Appunto
dai dai problemi che abbiamo almeno per
qualche ora
Oramai
sono dieci anni che sono in carrozzina
se mi guardi indietro
di strada ne ho fatta Certo l'ho fatto
in maniera diversa ma la mia strada l'ho
fatta Ora ho una mia nuova normalità o
una compagna di cui sono innamoratissimo
gli amici di sempre
e il mio solito lavoro e soprattutto
adesso ho una piena consapevolezza di
una forza interiore e una conoscenza di
me stesso che che prima forse non non
avevo
quello che la mia è una piccola storia
di rinascita come ce ne sono tante altre
a questo mondo quello che mi permetto di
consigliarvi è quando vi imbatterete i
momenti difficili o di sconforto non
fermatevi a contemplarli Ma guardatevi
intorno Tenetevi stretto quanto avete di
più importante e togliete ogni minimo
opportunità per per ricominciare perché
è un motivo per sorridere ci sarà sempre
sono sicuro che lo ritroverete
Ora vi lascio a un a un breve video
che è un piccolo esempio di
quello che è capace di produrre
l'adrenalina che è capace di produrre lo
sport o forse più probabilmente un
saggio di quel briciolo di pazzia Che
che si nasconde in ognuno di noi
siamo sono alla maratona di Venezia e
novembre del 2018
e ho appena fatto 39 km della maratona e
me ne mancano poco più di tre e Ma vi
posso assicurare che me ne sono sembrati
molti di più diciamo dalla mia posizione
vedevo due cose le transenne a sinistra
e le gondole a destra ho deciso
opportunamente credo di di stare sulla
sulla sinistra
ecco
diciamo il fatto che che oggi sia stato
qui a raccontarvi la mia storia
significa due cose la prima è che non
sono morta affogato
e la seconda cosa che quel traguardo
l'ho tagliato Grazie
[Applauso]